شو اخبارنا الاخرى قال رئيس الوزراء
العراقي محمد شياع السوداني ان بلاده لن
تسمح لاي مجموعات او اطراف بان تشن هجمات
على اراضي ايران انطلاقا من الاراضي
العراقيه اضاف السوداني في مؤتمر صحفييا
بطهران مع الرئيس الايراني ابراهيم رئيسي
ان حكومته تعتمده في سياستها الخارجيه
مبدا الاحترام وعدم التدخل في الشؤون
الداخليه للدول
الدستور
وعدم السماح لاي مجاميع او اي اطراف
استخدم الارض العراقيه للاضرار والاخلال
بها من ايران هذه سياسه العراق لن يكون
محطه او نقطه انطلاق للاضرار بدول الجوار
نعتمد سياسه في علاقات خارجيه العلاقه
المتوازنه مع الدول الشقيقه والصديق وفق
مبدا الاحترام المتبادل وعدم التدخل في
شؤون الداخليه